Jennie Garth and Tori Spelling a stir up
some a drag race drama you gotta make an
impression the Beverly Hills 90210 alums
were guests at judging the latest
episode of RuPaul's Drag Race
which featured a 902 enou themed
challenge contestant to Asia was playing
a character inspired by tiffani-amber
thiessen
and well the judges critique speaks for
itself as how do you say it
Bethenny just say that which we don't
speak this we never had that which which
we don't speak up the shade Tiffany
explained her side of the backstory here
to Howard Stern in 2012 you were best
friends on 90210 with Jennie Garth
mmm-hmm and now you don't even talk
something went down well I mean I think
there's a lot of things um we were very
very close even though when I first
started 90210 the girls were not very
nice to me when I came unto the chicken
why because you started in later than I
yes I kind of sort of replaced shannen
doherty on the show when Shannon left
and that was considered a threat I guess
I don't know I don't know what the real
reason was they just I think having
somebody new come into an already very
successful kind of you know show that's
run on its own to have a new kind of
energy was probably hard
you